.
BRIAN: ONLY THING WE COULD WATCH
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
APPRECIATE IT, ASHLEY.
MEANWHILE, KEEP IT WITH
BASKETBALL.
PROTESTERS IN NEW YORK CITY
HOLDING A RALLY IN SUPPORT OF
NBA SUPER STAR KYRIE IRVING OF
BROOKLYN AND AGAINST THE VACCINE
MANDATE THAT BENCHED HIM.
[CHANTING KYRIE]
STAND WITH KYRIE.
BRIAN: WHILE SOME CHARGE THE
HOME OPENER TRYING TO GET.
IN NEDGES GUEST PEACEFULLY
PROTESTED THE STATE'S VACCINE
MANDATE.
THE FREEDOM RALLY JOINS US NOW.
JOHN, WHY GO BAT FOR KYRIE
IRVING?
>> SO KYRIE IS JUST SOMEBODY ON
A BIG SCALE THAT'S FACING WHAT
WE, LIKE HEALTHCARE WORKERS,
TEACHERS, AND CITY WORKERS ARE
NOW FACING.
HE IS JUST ON A VERY BIG SCALE.
AND HE LOST HIS JOB IN A VERY,
VERY BIG PUBLIC EYE.
BRIAN: SO DID YOU, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME IS I'M
AN UNSUNG HERO IN HEALTHCARE AND
KYRIE IS A HERO AROUND THE WORLD
THROUGH SPORTS.
AND ENTERTAINMENT.
SO THIS IS JUST A VERY BIG
PICTURE OF WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
EVERYDAY, AVERAGE PERSON.
AND A SUPER STAR FORMAT.
SO THIS IS KIND SATISFY
SPRINGBOARD TO GET THE MESSAGE
OUT THERE IN GENERAL THAT THESE
MANDATES RUN JUST AND AFFECTING
EVERYBODY.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SLEEPING
ON IT.
BRIAN: I HEAR YOU, WE SEE IT
FROM MASSACHUSETTS FIREFIGHTERS
TO THE COPS AND WE SEE IT IN
SEATTLE.
WE SEE IT IN WASHINGTON STATE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT IN NEW
YORK 36,000 COULD LOSE THEIR
JOBS TWO WEEKS BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
WE'RE UNDERSTANDING IT.
JOHN, YOU ARE A CT SCAN
TECHNOLOGIST.
AND YOU WERE TOLD AFTER 15
YEARS, HIT THE ROAD YOU ARE
FIRED OVER IN STATEN ISLAND.
HOW HARD WAS IT TO GET THIS
GROUP TOGETHER?
WHAT MADE UP THIS PROTEST?
>> OKAY.
SO, NEW YORK FREEDOM RALLY IS --
HAS ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
WE USUALLY DO, WHICH IS DRAWN UP
TO 2,000 PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
AND IT'S NOT LARGELY REPORTED ON
TV, BUT IT'S HAPPENING EVERY
WEEKEND ON WEEKDAYS.
THIS TIME WE ACTUALLY TEAMED UP
WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER, GREATER
NEW YORK.
AND HAWK NEWSOM BROUGHT SOME
PEOPLE DOWN REVEREND McCAUL
BROUGHT SOME PEOPLE DOWN.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT UNIFYING ON
ONE COMMON GOAL.
I KNOW THAT BLM IS VERY UPSET
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON AND HOW IT
IS AFFECTING THEIR COMMUNITY.
THEY HAVE PLEDGED TO HAVE FIVE
DAYS OF ACTION.
SO THINGS ARE JUST -- SEEMS TO
BE HEATING UP AS EVERYBODY IS
UNIFYING FOR THE SAME CAUSE.
BRIAN: WHY STORM THE GATE?
>> WELL, THE GATES -- SO WHAT
HAPPENED, I KIND OF SAW THAT ALL
GO DOWN AND THEN THE POLICE KIND
OF JUST LET EVERYONE GO AND
STAND RIGHT WHERE YOU WALK IN.
AS WHAT HAPPENED IN THE FRONT, I
WASN'T CLOSE TO IT SOME OF THE
CAMERA CREW I HAD WITH ME WERE
ABLE TO GET SOME IMAGES.
I FEEL LIKE THE MAIN GOAL FOR
THAT IS KIND OF CREATING A
DISTURBANCE IT WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT BY THE MEDIA
HAD IT NOT OCCURRED THAT'S THE
THOUGHT BEHIND IT.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN
PLAY NOW.
BRIAN: SOME DIFFERENT PEOPLE
FEEL THE SAME WAY VACCINE ALL
DIFFERENT EDUCATION AND
BACKGROUND.
THEY ARE NOT BEING LISTENED TO.
JOHN, THANKS FOR STANDING UP.
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
>> YEAH.
AND BILL FOR MAYOR BECAUSE IS HE
GOING TO TURN ALL OF THIS AROUND
FOR US AND IS HE GOING TO SAVE
THE CITY.
CITY WORKERS ARE MEETING TODAY.